[Musique]
mt sensibilité là on ne devra pas
seulement n'ai jamais dit dans une phase
très basses ministre eli wallach cerner
je dois leur lâcheté ou la fcol finale à
sens unique candidat pour que talisman
chaude à simoncelli osman horoz madrane
azumi a amélioré à savoir ce qui m'a
pris matériaux révoltés par cela
bonjour
rona tu te souviens de notre deuxième
jour en palestine
je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier
c'était la première fois qu'on sortait
du camp de réfugiés pour se balader et
découvrir les alentours de bethléem on
roulait sur la rue principale
elle nous expliquer toutes les
particularités de la ville et même où se
situaient les graffitis de banksy mais
tu sais ce qui m'a le plus marqué c'est
ce qu'on a vu lorsqu'on s'est arrêté
tu te rappelles en face de la station
d'essence au l'allongé on l'a observé
contempler et même photographié il y
avait des graffitis de toutes parts
réalisé par des internationaux afin de
dénoncer et d'éveiller les consciences
sur l'occupation israélienne ils étaient
colorés contrastée par l'espoir et le
désespoir entremêlées la face à lui face
au mur long de 700 km et haut de huit
mètres je me souviens nous l'avons
trouvé beau
mais quelque chose sonne faux que savez
vous sur la palestine
l'avez vous oubliez ce soir notre voix
résonne au nom de ce jeune palestinien
nous l'avons rencontré lors de notre
séjour dans le camp de réfugiés déchets
en cisjordanie c'est dans le cadre d'un
atelier d'art que ce jeune a voulu nous
présenter son tableau pour décrire sa
réalité mais de quelle réalité
parle-t-on au juste
la palestine ne représentent aujourd'hui
plus que 8% de ce qu'elle représentait
il y à 71 1 an des transferts de
populations ont lieu depuis la fin des
années 40
suite à la fondation de l'état d'israël
sur le territoire palestinien
aujourd'hui encore les réfugiés
palestiniens représentent la plus grande
catégorie de réfugiés au monde la
question palestinienne ne peut donc être
abordée sans la question des réfugiés
au moins trois quarts des palestiniens
dans le monde sont des déplacés forcé
depuis 2014
un demi million de palestiniens ont été
forcés de quitter gaza l'onu l'a déjà
annoncé
si la situation ne s'améliore pas gaza
sera je cite inhabitable inadapté à la
vie humaine d'ici 2020 nous voyons pas
ces chiffres que la crise humanitaire en
palestine transcende les générations
mais comment at on pu trouver sur mur
beau les palestiniens connaissent bien
assez leur réalité pour que la
communauté internationale n'est besoin
de la leur rappeler ses dessins sont
peut-être simplement du mauvais côté
nous avons choisi de vous présenter ce
dessin et cette photographie non
seulement pour porter la voix des
palestiniens que l'on entend peu mais
aussi
surtout pour introduire un concept aussi
banal que frustrant celui de la
normalisation
on peut aussi parler de dissonance
cognitive
chacun d'entre nous est à la recherche
d'un équilibre cognitif celle équilibre
entre nos valeurs et notre comportement
lorsque c'était qu'il aimerait rompu
parce qu'on se situe face à une nouvelle
réalité
on ressent comme une tension un malaise
qui nous pousse à vouloir rectifier
c'était un équilibre mais comme la
situation ne change pas on va soit
adapté nos valeurs soient notre
comportement à cette nouvelle réalité
prenons deux exemples du quotidien
qui d'entre vous fume et 17 fameuse
phrase il faut bien mourir de quelque
chose aux biens combien d'entre vous
disent toujours c'est est-ce qu'ils en
soirée non mais ça va
in de temps en temps c'est pas si grave
dans le premier cas vous avez modifié
vos valeurs et dans le deuxième
votre comportement combien d'entre nous
passent devant leurs semblables et ne
les voit pas les personnes sans abri
sont face à nous et parce que cette
réalité nous est trop insupportable on
décide soit de passer tout droit devant
elle sans les regarder
soit on les regarde mais on se dit
qu'elles sont responsables de leur
propre misère ainsi pour réussi à
confronter cette situation de tous les
jours on finit par supporter
l'insupportable par normaliser la
normale on ne se rendait pas compte de
tout ce qu'implique ses dessins sur le
mur pour les palestiniens
jusqu'à ce que ce jeune nous prennent
par surprise et nous disent que pour lui
le mur est une intention est une
structure salle
il choisit donc l'art pour dénoncer
normalisation de sa réalité sa réalité
c'est celle d'un camp et d'une
occupation
au total il existe aujourd'hui 58 camp
de réfugiés palestinien reconnu le camp
de ce jeune déchets destinés à
accueillir 3000 personnes au milieu du
xxème siècle en accueillent aujourd'hui
17000 sa densité est telle qu'on
pourrait le confondre avec une ville
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on l'a vu pour la
première fois en hauteur depuis une
terrasse on n'arrivait pas à déterminer
où s'arrêtait le camp et où commencer la
ville voisine mais quelque chose sonne
faux
pourquoi ces camps ressemble-t-il temps
à des villes
l'état se repose sur les agences de
réhabilitation des camps qui ont été
mises en place dans l'urgence il se
déresponsabilise ainsi de son devoir de
protéger sa population et cette agence
par nécessité devient un quasi état
alors qu'être réfugiés devaient être une
perspective de court terme
les humanitaires les fiches dans le
temps et maintient le statu quo le
caractère non permanent d'être réfugié
se heurte ici à 71,1 endettent
humanitaire le temporel devient
permanent l'exceptionnelle devient
l'habituel on normalise le but de
l'atelier d'art était que ces enfants
réfugiés illustre ce qu'ils ressentent
qu'ils se situent dans ce contexte on
leur a demandé de nous dessiner leur
quotidien ils nous ont dessiné
l'occupation tous les tableaux de
l'exposition nous ont démontré la même
réalité l'esprit des enfants est occupée
par l'occupation
que ce soit à travers les couleurs
utilisées en majorité du noir du gris et
du rouge ou par les thématiques abordées
la violence les martyrs le droit au
retour mais aussi l'espoir
face à ce constat nous nous posons sans
cesse les mêmes questions où sont donc
passés les beaux coloris de notre
enfance mais où sont donc passés les
doux rêves de notre jeunesse
il semblerait que l'occupation ne laisse
plus aucune place à l'innocence les
nouvelles générations naissent
grandissent dans un contexte de crise
humanitaire comme unique réalité la
normalisation d'une situation de crise à
long terme et dangereuse car elle
maintenir le statu quo et met sous
silence des souffrances qui devrait se
faire entendre parce qu'on considère une
situation trop compliqué pour s'en
soucier ont fini par l'accepter
une situation peut être complexe mais
elle n'est jamais compliqué car derrière
elle se cache toujours le mot liberté
le mot dignité mais l'empathie ne va pas
de soi sentir ce que l'autre ressent
n'est pas évident alors on préfère se
dire que le monde est comme ça que ces
personnes sont simplement né au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment
puis on oublie peut-être que l'ultime
phase du processus de normalisation soit
l'oubli ou alors les deux s'imbriquent
et la rési leur dangerosité
dans une situation de conflit ou de
crise c'est toujours un peuple pris mais
contre le presseur c'est toujours des
libertés auquel on aspire normalisée
c'est renoncer à ses libertés
mais comment éduquer ces nouvelles
générations et leur faire comprendre que
cette situation n'est pas une fatalité
que cette situation n'a en fait rien de
normal
l'une des plus belles solutions que les
palestiniens aient trouvé est la
résistance non-violente notamment par le
biais de l'éducation
il est important que ces enfants
comprennent
ne doivent pas se contenter de vivre
dans l'humiliation et la discrimination
des centres culturels leur apprennent à
résister à forger leur esprit critique
par exemple à travers l'art et nous
quelle est notre place face à la
normalisation
il s'agit d'un mécanisme de survie le
cerveau crée naturellement des
raccourcis mentaux le premier pas est
d'en être conscient lorsque vous passez
tout droit devant une personne qui a
besoin d' aide et qu'instinctivement
vous trouvez des excuses pour ne pas
agir
rendez vous compte de ce qu'il se passe
et ils conscience que vous êtes en train
de normaliser la situation d'une
personne dont vous ne connaissez pas
l'histoire
lorsqu on s'est rendu compte qu'on avait
trouvé beau un mur qui là pour diviser
deux peuples on a ressenti un profond
désespoir
on s'est sentis coupables mais at on le
droit de nous sentir découragés
alors que son plein d'espoir ce serait
oublier que nos combats sont communs
notre liberté et leur liberté
il faut donc aller au delà des
apparences des préjugés et des ressentis
partir dans une région sous perpétuelle
tension est une manière de ne pas se
fier à ce que nous disent les médias et
les gens autour de nous on y découvre un
peuple souffrant mais résistant humilié
mais aussi fier d'exister contribuant à
notre échelle pour ne pas perdre la
sensibilité au monde qui nous entoure
soyons des acteurs conscients
parce que tous les murs même ceux de
l'esprit sont faits pour être surpassée
[Applaudissements]